hi reggie how are you done good to see
you well yeah very well thank you so
happy to be here thank you so much
how are you
villains amazing what an amazing place
look at it it's
unbelievable hello the druva speaker
language called gandhi they're welcoming
ritual for visitors involves downing a
stiff drink made from fermented fruit
called malwa
how you start yes actually this is a
traditional drink so first you say all
the people
and after yes you put one drop in the
earth we waste it yeah
oh i smell strong
so it's not good
it's strong yeah strong very strong
because tribal people are very strong
people yeah i'm sure tribal people are
very strong but that is ridiculous now
you are
good to see you guys
[Music]
holy crap that is extraordinary
everybody seems so chilled here it's
like having cocktails in the afternoon
laid back relaxed dunny
cheers
christ for a minute i thought she was
dead
now this is what i've traveled into the
wild for the chutney of the deruvas
taste it um
jesus christ
it's hot
yeah but it is absolutely delicious i
mean really dish fresh i'm never going
to touch mango chutney for the rest of
my life but uh this is not a fruit
how do you make that if you like uh come
with me in the jungle i'll show you what
is this thing
okay there's a secret go into the jungle
yeah yeah how far in let's look good
not sure actually sometimes two
kilometers fast sometimes a half
kilometer far
what is it
inside that chutney that makes it so
bloody delicious
[Music]
it seems the mystery ingredient is at
the top of this 80-foot tree
watching
this making a step have you heard of a
ladder
ladder no no no no not tomorrow one
thing isn't there yeah i'll show you
later later
so
that was a surprise to you what about a
safety rope
nor safety though
[Music]
he's cutting down a branch with what
looks like a nest on it
watch out
oh jesus
so this is the thing garden
that's it yeah oh my god
so the chutney's made out of ants
and they bite they're everywhere
that's [ __ ]
christ almighty
aren't they poisonous
[ __ ] when they bite they bite how does
that make a chutney ants
and eggs and egg
so we're using the eggs yeah eggs and
ants both so it's like an ant
caviar yeah
so they're the they're the eggs
look at this
oh come on
tasty
hmm
tell me who's test
it's it's sour yeah sour butter salad
yeah like tamarind yeah like tamarind
but it's uh there's a little bit of
sweetness there as well when you burst
the eggs inside
this is why i've come to india any good
chef loves fresh ingredients
for such a tasty dish the chutney is
easy to make
red chili salt and ginger are ground up
with some ants and their eggs it's rich
in protein in a place where meat is hard
to come by
so you use 50 eggs and 50 ants
wow
that's what you call a chutney
yeah better than that goodbye manga
rajunish and his friend hiro have a dish
to go with the chutney
it's a sort of chicken hot pot
first the chicken is mixed with a paste
made from chili garlic and ginger then
it's put into the basket made from woven
leaves from the sal tree
it's a little bit water so it helps to
steam the chicken it's staying for
foster
so now we are stitching
unbelievable
[Music]
it's like she's covering the chicken
with
pastry
yeah but it's not it's a leaf totally
different so that goes inside
the fire
[Music]
a little too far
you can't turn down the heat or turn up
the heat
oh [ __ ]
are you sure that's going to be cooked
[Music]
ah
oven gloves
[Music]
tell me two things
delicious okay you know really good
thank you so much
thank you so much
well done
hero
staying with the deruva tribe has been a
real eye-opener incredible they have
nothing yet they've developed these
ingenious techniques on how to cook
delicious food
quite touching
amazing stuff sema's got an invite to
cook with a real rajput prince nicknamed
bozo
he's an expert on desert cuisine and
champions radishan's culinary traditions
hello bozo hi
how are you welcome what an amazing
place welcome to rajasthan thank you so
much we're gonna head off to the desert
okay and do a bit of um cooking and all
that and rest of them are gonna join us
later okay look forward to it
shall we hello thank you yeah please
yeah that was a journey and a half i'm
the only hoi polloi around here bozos
are cut above
his real name is parikshit
and he's a maharaja of john paul's
nephew how old is this
this is this is this has been there
since 1952.
that's fine there we go
we're traveling 55 kilometers into the
desert to bozo's camp
amazing
it looks beautiful it is nothing good
amazing it's just awesome raw so we're
unstuck
i'm cooking for bozo's desert dinner
party tonight and he's teaching me a
slow cooked meat dish called could god
gosh made with goat
very basic there's nothing much no
there's no finery in this
as i call it in india so this is
basically tenderizing the goat it's just
tenderizing the goat this is something
you grew up with this is what yeah this
is this is pretty much the kind of stuff
where one sort of always grew up seeing
all the elders like uncles and they were
my father and they were in cooking when
we went out shooting initially
now with the masalas
the goat leg will be smothered in a
masala mix made with chilli and turmeric
and now
for one local spices it's very
indigenous to rajasthan you won't
probably get it anywhere else it's
something which we call over here
kachori cuttery yeah and it's it's it's
it's a family of milan
and it's
it works as a tenderizer it also so it
gives it that little tangy flavor
fresh kachori comes from a small brown
melon and is only found in rajasthan
mix the ghee mix the ghee
wow
this helps to keep it juicy
and doesn't let you know things dry up
too much take it out now comes the
surprising bit
we moisten sackcloth and muslin then lay
banana leaves on top which we'll use to
wrap up the goat
now
what we need to do is get the indian
bread
bread the chapatis party
so it's almost like a wellington like a
goat wellington we have a filler beef
wellington okay a traditional you know
sort of 70s retro dish wrapped in a
pancake
then pastry okay it's lined with
mushrooms so yeah it absorbs it it
absorbs yeah that that's what it's uh
that's the general idea it's a whole
meal itself yeah yeah this particular
recipe was brought to me by one of our
old old family chefs he's still around
can't see very much but he's he's
probably one of the best
uh cooks i've known now
for the messy part right what do you
have to do is take the masala massage in
massage it into the meat and the rest of
it
to spread around everywhere yep
okay good
so
i can see bozo's not a man that likes
getting his hands dirty he's used to
having servants around
so okay here we go
take this
wow
try to hold that and then come as you
come around well i think it'll hold
itself now okay right you can do that
but i think i i just all right chef
i'm sorry about that no no no i was
trying to help you get me through the
shitty [ __ ]
you're in there doing the glamorous bits
because you want to wrap it up yeah
right now you can wrap that up
[ __ ]
see you next tuesday go on come back
come back we need you we need to do the
ditch
come back please
please gordon please i'm coming back we
can't finish it without you
thank god i wasn't your chef in your
palace 20 years ago i swear to god your
ice cream would never be the same so i
was trying to hold that on there for you
so you can wrap the rest
i think bozo considers me good below
stairs material
any other little shitty [ __ ] you want
me to do chef if you pulled out i'll
just
attach it right thank you thank you
thank you
nice and tight
now we've wrapped it up we just need a
bit of wire to just
tie it up and it's
300 years recipe is ready to be cooked
okay where's the oven yeah because the
oven is going to be something which
you my dear friend are going to dig oh
come on come on hey
where are you i've made your spices
yeah i've wiped your nose i've peeled
your garlic i've chopped the onions well
you know you've got to get the whole
desert experience the hair is displayed
oh come on that's the ground you've got
to dig up a bit we need about
three feet deep
three feet wide yeah and three feet
right long this is a square bit you're
spoiled
i am
and you know what better way to get
someone as great as chef as you to do
this for us you just need to bid your
back a little more i suppose
and you might need to come around this
way
i'm imagining that this is a certain
person's face
that bit more and then we are done
last time i dug this deep
i was in the second household of britain
it's gedness
have you heard of skegness no i haven't
yeah
yeah we used to holiday there
fish and chips
and dinner so what were you digging for
there i was playing sandcastles oh
that's perfect
[Music]
now we're surrounding the wrap goat with
hot coals and burying it in sand
pit cooking was developed by the desert
nomads who wanted to travel light
without cooking utensils
[Music]
that one is perfect
now it's going to be in there for say
about two hours
let me pull it out
and
i'll hope for the best really i think i
deserve a beer i think i do too you
deserve [ __ ] all right oh god come on i
taught you everything
okay
bozo's dinner guests aren't slumming out
here his sevens have laid on some home
comforts in the dunes
i feel like bloody captain caveman
that looks fantastic
it's just a red we need to open it up a
bit
nice all right
got the knife and forks
there we are please excuse my fingers
thank you
which one is please
bozo that is delicious
what a wonderful way of cooking goat
what's nice is the
you're getting all the spices without
being you know chili hot it's wet with
the bread around the outside which i
didn't think would be
tasty but the bread absorbs the juices
it takes the juices and it's sort of
pregnant with the spices so there's one
thing i've learned tonight since being
in the desert
is sticking to tradition tradition the
tradition well done
[Music]